[Music]
my name is Vikki Caspi I'm a professor
in the physics department at McGill
University and director of the McGill
space Institute and I am going to talk
to you about fast radio bursts which is
a new new Astrophysical puzzle something
that we've only really understood exists
in the past decade and which we we
really we really don't understand so
this it's a sort of an animation to just
get you in the right headspace about
what these objects are so when I say
fast radio bursts what I mean is that
there's these short bursts of light and
by short I mean typically a few
milliseconds thousandth of a second that
are going off all over the sky all the
time and pretty often roughly we think
around a thousand times per day across
the whole sky and we we really don't
know what they are now you know this
this picture that you're looking at it
just to get you in sort of the right
transient headspace they come they burst
then they're gone but they're fast radio
bursts so we're detecting them not in
the optical light that you're seeing
right now but in the light of radio
waves the sort that the you've heard
already about radio telescopes but
here's here's just another picture of a
radio telescope here on the cover of a
recent issue of Nature the prestigious
science journal where we reported some
of the results I'm going to tell you
about today just earlier this year one
of the things that we do know about
these this phenomenon is that these
bursts are almost certainly coming from
very very far outside our Milky Way
galaxy and in fact we believe they're
coming from cosmological distances
that is from distances that are pre
Schabel fractions of the entire size of
the universe now how do we how do we
know this you know in astronomy
measuring distances is one of the
biggest challenges we have especially
for objects because something could be
nearby and appear you know you get some
light from it so it'd be intrinsically
pretty faint or if it's really really
far away and you get the same amount of
light that means it's really
intrinsically very bright so determining
the distance is crucial in these when
you're trying to understand a puzzle and
when I'm telling you I think they're far
outside the galaxy indeed at
cosmological distances that's quite a
statement they have to be very very very
powerful indeed and so powerful
ubiquitous and completely unexpected and
unpredicted very interesting now why do
we think they're so far away well it
comes down to the fact that they we
detect from them radio waves and when I
say radio you're probably picturing
something like this and indeed this does
detect radio waves but it detects
terrestrial radio waves and one big
difference between the way we use that
device the radio and how we do radio
astronomy is that when you want to hear
some noise you want to study listen to
something on your radio you tuned it to
a very specific frequency so I don't
know Toronto radio stations in Montreal
if you want to listen to CBC like I do I
turn to 88.5 if I want to listen to pop
music or rather my teenage daughter's
want to listen to pop music they turn to
92.5 and the reason you don't hear
Whitehouse prep press briefings at the
same time is they all say or Nicki Minaj
is because you can tune to different
frequencies and the station's they only
radiate at those specific frequencies
but in astrophysics source isn't
particularly fast radio bursts they
don't emit at specific radio frequencies
they emit at all of them and they emit
it all of them at the same time and we
receive all of those frequencies at the
same time but not quite almost at the
same time
and that's very important so the first
fast radio bursts that was ever
discovered we call it fondly the Lorimer
bursts I'll explain shortly why and this
is a technical plot of it but judging
from the questions at the intermission
you guys can totally handle this first
look at the inset this plot here where
you can see the the bursts there it is
this is radio intensity versus time so
time is on the x-axis here you see the
bursts of radio waves that's what you
should be picturing and I talked about
fast radio bursts but in the larger
picture you see what's actually
happening so time is still on the x-axis
here but on the y-axis it's radio
frequency and you know a typical radio
station would just be this actually this
problem probably is a radio station very
irritating but some noise in our data
one line at all times at one frequency
but the fast radio bursts actually comes
in at all frequencies but at different
frequencies at different times even
though at the source
it was emitted all at the same time so
what you can see is at the high radio
frequency so this is this is we call
this a full band a very wide band of at
the very highest frequencies the burst
arrives first and then it's delayed in a
very special way and this is what we
call a propagation effect even though
the source emitted the burst all at the
same time the radio waves are delayed
because of stuff in the intervening
matter so in the in the in the galaxies
or in the intergalactic medium and that
stuff is a free electrons it doesn't so
much matter but there's stuff there that
delays radio waves and it's the degree
of that delay the time delay from when
the pulse arrives at the highest radio
frequency to when it arrives at the
lowest radio frequencies that's telling
us that these objects are at
cosmological distances so an object
that's really nearby they'd all come at
the same time an object that is very we
call it dispersed that where there's a
huge delay that means it's coming from
very far away and I can show you
so I should just mention the Lorimer
burst was detected at the Parkes radio
telescope in Australia which has done a
huge amount of the work in this field so
far and I promise I tell you why it's
Lorimer bracelets because whoops it's
because the astronomer founded his name
is duncan Lorimer and there is now I
said it's free electrons and I will it's
a little bit technical but I really want
I think I want to show it to you this is
what a typical galaxy looks like it's
not our galaxy you can't take a picture
of your galaxy when you're sitting in it
just like you can't take a picture of
the outside of your house when you're
inside it so I've taken a Milky Way
light galaxy look down on it now this is
a contour plot of our own Milky Way
where these this is this cross here is
the center of the galaxy and our Sun is
at that little white dot a little dot
over there and there's some you know
schematic spiral arms drawn in there but
what all the other lines are this is a
contour plot so I'm sure you've seen
contour plots like relief maps things
like that it's a contour plot of lines
of constant a number of electrons and so
why am I telling you this for any object
when you measure that sweep when you
measure the delay from the high
frequencies to the low frequencies you
should be able to look on a map and the
greater the delay the further away the
object is and we do this all the time
with neutron stars with radio pulses
that you're going to hear about from
Scott ransom later today this is how we
determine distance to these objects we
measure that sweep rate but coming back
to the Lorimer bursts in these arcane
units the maximum allowed by our galaxy
in that direction for this delay here in
these crazy units is 25 whereas the
Lorimer burst was 375 over 10 times what
our galaxy can possibly account for
that's sweep rate that the degree of
sweep the degree of delay it's
impossible as far as we know to account
for in our galaxy alone and this is the
major clue the major reason we think
fast radio bursts have to be extremely
distant
now so as I said it has to be way
outside our galaxy because there's not
enough electrons in our Milky Way to
account for that sweep and if it's way
outside our galaxy and if it's you know
at a cosmological distance as we think
these objects have to be extremely
bright intrinsically and so this is the
mystery and what are they we don't know
so what are fast radio bursts currently
and this is with great respect to my
theorist colleagues there are more
theories than there are events that
we've measured so far there's about a
couple dozen of these events mostly
detected with the Parkes telescope and
so there's all sorts of ideas what they
could be when something goes boom in the
sky
you think of an exploding star like
Loras just talked about or perhaps
colliding neutron stars that we believe
also happens in the universe there's
also ideas of comets impacting neutron
stars or evaporating black holes or
there's all sorts of interesting ideas
but the bottom line is we don't know and
you might say well if it could be an
exploding star why don't you just go and
look why don't you commandeer an 8 meter
class telescope on the on the
mountaintop in Hawaii and just point it
at the fast radio bursts or where it
happened and have a look and I would
love to do that we would love to do that
the problem is that the radio telescopes
like Parkes
that detect these objects tell you I
sort of over there in other words they
don't have very good resolution on the
sky they tell you roughly where it is
but if you were to look in that patch as
a thousand galaxies that patches is too
large to know exactly where the fast
radio bursts came from so without
knowing where it came from you can see
didn't even come from a galaxy you can't
know but that's recently changed so
we're very excited by this this is
actually a catalog of all the known fast
radio bursts and I want to draw you said
I'm just showing it you could Google
this if you want to bring it up and have
a look and enjoy some of these wonderful
numbers I was going to circle one of
them this is the that column is showing
you the telescopes that detected the No
fast rate of your person there's one in
there that was detected not by the
Parkes radio telescope but by the
Arecibo radio telescope which is the
until recently the world's largest
telescope in Puerto Rico this is in
Puerto Rico it's about three football
fields across 300 meters across you
could see it's a few hundred meters
there I'll just point out this is a
catwalk this is a catwalk so if you want
you can walk from this this beautiful
Science Center our Cebu Science Center
wonderful you can walk on this catwalk
to the top and in fact there we are that
is me at the top of Arecibo very
exciting standing right at the top of
the catwalk over there
with my colleagues Paul ray from the
naval research laboratory and more
McLaughlin from West Virginia University
and if you zoom in yes my knuckles are
white it is scary up there Arecibo is
also famous because it was featured
heavily in the James Bond movie
Goldeneye starring Pierce Brosnan and if
you decide to rent that movie you will
see him running on that catwalk but
actually it's not him it's a stunt
double
because Pierce Brosnan was too afraid to
run on the catwalk and so I'm very proud
to say I've done things James Bond was
too afraid to do but here it is this is
the fast radio bursts that was
discovered at Arecibo by our research
group and you can see here the tell-tale
sweep you have x-axis is time and the
y-axis again is radio frequency and
there you see it hi radio frequencies
arriving early and sweeping through and
there it is once we've in software
delayed all of this and and corrected
for the effect and there's the burst and
this was very exciting because it was
the first time that a fast radio bursts
had been detected at a telescope other
than parks which made everybody go Hugh
I guess these are real because if
they're all detected in one system it's
little but yes we've just definitely
detected this but that wasn't the end of
the excitement with us without this
object because to our amazement this
object repeats and you know when you're
trying to study a puzzle you're trying
to understand and whether or not what
these things are the
as a gift and this was a surprise to us
we have looked my colleagues that Parkes
had looked at some of the spots on the
sky over and over again never seen one
repeat this one repeated it took us
months actually we was starid and
nothing would happen and then suddenly
one day ten burs and now by now we've
seen many dozens of bursts this who has
got a lot of press there of it as Paul
Schultz was a PhD student actually who
made this discovery was very very
exciting and it's exciting because once
you know where to look and you know that
it's going to go off again and again you
can point a different kind of telescope
at it this is an array of radio
telescopes called an interferometer and
using this kind of telescope you can
pinpoint very precisely where the object
is so has spreading out a bunch of radio
telescopes and using them all together
lets you pinpoint on the sky exactly
where it is
and so you know you want to you want to
go hunting first you know you want to go
fishing where you know you know you're
going to catch something and so that is
what we did and very it took months
again this took months we took that
telescope called The Very Large Array
which is in New Mexico and observed over
and over again nothing happened finally
one day it went off and you can see the
burst here the way the interferometer
shows that the black circles were the
uncertainty regions prior to the VLA
observations with just from Arecibo and
you can see here now it's pinpointed
very very precisely on the sky and that
was very exciting
so first the roots it's because of the
repetition that we were able to do this
and with with it pinpointed on the sky
oh yes and this is you can see with the
VLA the same sweep and it's exactly the
same amount of sweep as expected and
there's the burst and with that boom in
the VLA and actually we got nine more
booms with the VLA so there was no no
problem then we could go to the eight
meter telescope on the mountaintop
Hawaii we went to the Gemini telescope
immediately once we had this position
and we could go and see what was there
to our amazement so here is now the
localized position and here's the
optical image where there is actually a
very very faint galaxy there so in some
sense it's no surprise that the fast
radio bursts is located at galaxy but
what was amazing is this is not the sort
of galaxy we expected you know when you
have an object like this you expect it
to be where most stars and most gas are
located which is in a big galaxy and
those are lots of big galaxies on the
sky but this is located we call it a
dwarf galaxy something like a few
percent of the mass of our Milky Way and
right now you know sometimes native
science is kind to you it answers some
questions by giving you repeating FRB
and in other ways it just opens more
questions why would this event this
unique object be located in so puny a
galaxy that's we just really don't know
but the good news is yes indeed this is
these objects they're definitely at
cosmological distances now that we've
detected the galaxies we can determine
its distance very precisely and indeed
these things really are cosmological his
work done by McGill postdoc shri harsh
Tendulkar and so this got quite a bit of
press here was the New York Times they
they made this little app showing how we
localized it and and there's the Gemini
image and that flash is fake obviously
because they didn't see it optically and
Dennis Overby wrote that it's probably
because we found in the galaxy is
probably ordinary physics and I got over
ordinary physics like I'd like to go to
his house and bring an FRB in the middle
of the night and set it off and see how
ordinary he finds it but it was already
interesting to see the contrast and how
these different press places reacted
this was the New York Times ordinary
physics
the New York Post on the other hand
whoops the New York Post said that it
could be aliens
this we did not say that we do not think
it's aliens so where do we stand with
fast radio bursts at least one of these
objects repeats and clearly colliding
neutron stars or exploding stars you
can't do it over and over and over again
it rules out a huge class of models for
these objects with just just this one
object now it's only for that one object
and we have yet to see another fast
radio bursts repeat even though we're
looking we're looking and does sometimes
take months so so far we start
scratching your heads we should be
seeing more repeats we haven't yet and
it opens a lot of questions do all fast
radio bursts repeat do all afar bees
repeat or are there two classes some
these that repeats and this is you know
two totally different phenomena we don't
know and what is the bursting story then
it just comes back to the repeater it's
producing a huge amount of energy and
over and over and over again that's
interesting how does it do that and why
is it in a tiny little galaxy so these
are questions we don't know the answers
to we're thinking very hard about it and
one of the ways to solve the problem is
to find more of them and see how many
repeats are they all in little tiny
galaxies and we think we're going to be
finding a lot more very soon using the
telescope that Matt Dobbs described to
you earlier today which was originally
designed for mapping hydrogen hydrogen
through the distant universe at
cosmological distances and doing
cosmology but which turns out the same
exact design is fantastic for detecting
fast radio bursts I don't think we could
have chosen a better design and that's
because as he explained it sees a huge
area of the sky at the same time and for
transient science where you don't know
where it's gonna go off when the best
way to detect sources is to look at a
large area all at once and so I ask you
to please stay tuned because Canada here
in Canada we're gonna make a lot of
headway on this problem very soon we
hope to be detecting not so I told you
there's a couple
in the FRB catalog so far since 2007 we
think we're going to detect a couple
dozen per day with chime and that'll
give us a whole lot of new sources to
study in and understand and with that I
thank the funding and agencies and thank
you very much
could I ask you a quick question Viki if
these are all at cosmological distance
does that imply that they happened a
long time ago and that there aren't they
aren't happening now or now in the
relative sense so yes the ones that we
detect if there are cosmological
distances they occurred a long time in
the past that's true on the other hand
there's no reason to think that they
couldn't happen the more local universe
as well and we have even given some
thought to what would happen if one went
off in our own galaxy
it doesn't seem impossible it all
depends what these objects are how
common they are and how often they go
off per galaxy it's not impossible that
they could happen locally as well just
haven't been seen locally yes so it's
actually a really interesting question
how you would detect it if it had
happened locally because one of the
biggest problems we have in radio
astronomy is as terrestrial interference
and there's all sorts your cell phone
satellites everything makes all sorts of
noise and when we trying to tech these
objects we're sifting through a ton of
noise and we throw out all sorts of
signals that seem to us with this coming
that are being just too bright to be
real so if there had been a local one
it's not impossible we might have
actually ignored it and we are now
thinking of ways to solve that problem
without letting in the flood of you know
cell phone signals and all that